now I recently did a video on the
benefits of taking cold showers but of
course those benefits only occur if you
actually take a cold shower a lot of
people in the comments section just you
know kind of chickened out because
taking cold showers can be very very
uncomfortable so today I want to discuss
some tips how to do this and get the
benefits without the incredible painful
uncomfortableness that comes along with
taking cold showers the first thing you
need to know about cold shower is just
like any type of stress is that when our
bodies are too comfortable when we get
rid of too much stress our bodies weaken
and so adding a little stress in your
life if it's not overwhelming is a very
very positive thing whether it's
exercise intermittent fasting or even
taking a cold shower so let me just kind
of recap on the benefits
first thing and this is quite big is
your immune system greatly responds you
would think if you're out in the cold or
let's say it's raining or something that
you would get sick but in fact if the
stress is not overwhelming if you're not
outside too long you can actually
strengthen your immune system to the
point where you can resist pathogens so
there's huge immune benefits to cold
therapy okay that's number one now also
attached with that is inflammation now
I'm not just talking about inflammation
from an infection I'm talking about
inflammation from an autoimmune disease
talking about inflammation from
especially arthritis if you have
arthritis stiffness okay or pain cold
therapy can be huge for you and if you
combine several things at once you can
really strengthen your immune system as
well so if you combine exercise with uh
fasting and this cold therapy you can
basically bulletproof yourself against a
lot of pathogens and a lot of people
with Lyme disease get benefits from
doing this as well we have the immune
system benefits we also have brain
benefits I'm talking about both with
your mood and your cognitive function so
people who are depressed have anxiety
can benefit from this greatly also
cognitive benefits whether you want to
increase your focus your concentration
get more attention be more productive
cold therapy can help now when you're
exposed to cold therapy there is a huge
spike in certain neurotransmitters I'm
specifically talking about two
epinephrine and norepinephine okay now
epinephrine is also called adrenaline
okay now these two neurotransmitters
they act like hormones but they work
within the nervous system in the brain
and also in the adrenal gland through
the nervous system and part of the
adrenal the inside called the medulla is
all neurological tissue so your medulla
and the adrenal produces adrenaline or
noradrenaline as well as certain parts
of the brain and so when we think of the
sympathetic nervous system which is the
flight or fight a lot of times people
think cortisol and that's one hormone
but the other two are adrenaline and
noradrenaline in fact cold therapy you
can increase these two neurotransmitters
up to 550 and so when you have more
adrenaline in the body you're going to
be very very awake so it's going to wake
you up very very fast and then there's
all sorts of cascading effects that
occur from this adrenaline and nor
adrenaline you have increased production
of mitochondria that's the energy
factories in the cell and so just by
taking regular cold showers you can
increase the number of mitochondria in
your muscle cells and that's pretty wild
and so you're going to have more
capacity for energy and also an
increased ability to burn things like
fat and so cold therapy is actually very
beneficial to help you lose weight
specifically activating something called
Brown fat
now brown fat is different than white
fat Brown fat is tied into thermogenesis
temperature regulation so when you do
cold therapy you actually stimulate more
production of your brown fat which
basically has more mitochondria and
doing that can elevate your metabolism
and that brown fat also Taps into
calories from the white fat helping you
oxidize a lot fat so there are other
things that go beyond just diet and
exercise as far as losing weight now the
other really cool thing about cold
therapy is that you can improve your
blood sugars and make insulin more
sensitive so many people have a problem
with insulin resistance and so in other
videos I talk about apple cider vinegar
talk about melanium carbs exercise but
you can also do this called shower to
help your blood sugars which is quite
amazing and then the last big benefit I
want to just mention briefly is
longevity certain genes that are tied
into living longer are skin emulated
when you're out in the cold because of
the survival programs that are attached
to surviving when you're freezing to
death now the other side note I want to
mention about cold therapy is that when
you sleep at night especially when you
get into the Delta wave sleep which is
the Deep Sleep the overall quality of
the Delta weight sleep is improved if
your temperature in your room is
slightly cooler
and it's worsened if you're trying to
sleep when it's too hot out now
personally I like to just use a very
thin sheet and I like to be on the cold
side when I sleep I sleep much better
I'm a little bit cooler than if I'm too
hot and before I get into the tips
there's just one last really important
point I want to bring up about colds
here would be in relationship to your
circulation roughly your body has about
62 000 miles of circulatory vessels
throughout the body including the veins
and the arteries and the papillaries you
have a lot of vessels and there is
muscle regulating the vasoconstriction
and the vasodilation of that system so
when you're taking these cold showers
you are activating 62
000 miles of vessels which have muscles
and so you're creating this interesting
effect of vasoconstriction and
vasodilation and getting more blood flow
to a certain parts of your body that
might need it so in other words there's
a lot of positive things that are going
to happen if you can get up enough nerve
to do these cold cellos all right let's
start with number one what you do in the
shower is you start with a very warm
shower okay so you're taking a warm
shower and you're turning up really
really hot and then what you're going to
do is you're just going to basically on
a nice gradient start cooling it down
okay slowly until your body gets used to
it and then you're going to go colder
and colder and colder over a period of
time to do this very gradually so it's
not so painful starting out because the
biggest barrier that we're running into
is to ignore your body saying no don't
do it so for some reason your body has
this great resistance against being too
cold for example I'm from Wisconsin and
they used to have this Polar Bear Club
in Lake Michigan in the winter they
would all run out there and jump in Lake
Michigan I mean it gets cold in
Wisconsin now at the time I thought
these guys were crazy but now that I
know the benefits I probably would have
follow them and jump into Lake Michigan
at least I would attempt to do it all
right number two this tip can help just
um counter some of the shock to your
body so let's say for example you have
your shower on cold and you expose a
certain part of your body let's say your
chest okay you start to rub your chest
okay rub it as the cold is going on your
skin and that can help make things a lot
easier and because these cold receptors
are on the skin and they're superficial
so if you're rubbing them you'll tend to
numb some of the intensity of that cold
shocking uh sensation all right number
three you're going to go into this cold
water
with complete relaxation that's the
opposite of what most people do they're
kind of going into this uh with
exhilaration with this heightened fear
or whatever and they're not relaxed and
so it just makes things worse so you
want to just kind of go into this with
total relaxation it'll be a lot easier
for you to face this
um this change in temperature all right
and number four relates to number three
start slowing your breath down okay
breathing very slowly in for maybe four
to five seconds and out for four to five
seconds so the combination of being
relaxed and slow deep breaths can help
you push past the pain of this cold
number five turn on some music that you
really really like listening to certain
types of music can help you push through
the barriers it can also help distract
your mind from this sensation of being
very very cold number six is to do this
cold shower right after you've had some
intense exercise where you're sweating
it'll just help counter some of the heat
that you just generated so it'll be a
little bit easier number seven is just
not to overthink the same not to start
to even talk yourself into it just do it
without thinking just jump right in
there in the morning kind of trick
yourself into just doing it all right
number eight ideally over time I'm
talking over weeks you should go from
maybe 10 seconds 20 seconds 30 seconds
to 45 seconds to a minute and then up to
two minutes okay once a day that would
be awesome if you could do that so
normally at 30 seconds things should be
a little bit easier you'll start to feel
kind of a numbing effect and you'll
start to tolerate it more but that first
30 seconds is the hardest all right
number nine is just jump in the cold
shower but end with a very warm hot
shower they take away the
uncomfortableness of what you just
experienced so if you're going to take a
cold shower just in your mind realize
that it's going to end with some nice
comfortable pleasure moment okay number
10 when you go into this cold shower
just do one part of your body whether
it's your legs okay or maybe your left
arm and shoulder this is what you're
doing in a nice gradual gradient where
it's not too intense there's certain
parts of your body and then just keep
adding another part each time you do it
to make it easier and the last one
number 11 is just to turn the shower on
for a few seconds and then turn it off
for a few seconds on for a few seconds
off for a few seconds and that way
you're doing some type of intermittent
type exposure which definitely will
break up the intensity and the pain from
this uh cold sensation all right so now
I hope you have enough nerve to attempt
these cold showers okay now if you
haven't seen my other video on cold
showers and the benefits I think you
should check that out I put it up right
here